natürlich aber ich weiß dass der neffe
von clemens tönnies mit genies
verfeindet ist dass das dort
familienstreitigkeiten gibt ich kann das
nicht kommentieren ein einfaches nach
lesen der zeitungen in der zeit in der
ich wirtschaftsminister war wird ihnen
zeigen dass ich mit der fleischbrühe und
auch mit clemens tönnies nicht besonders
freundlich umgegangen bin aber es stimmt
er war er bereit dinge zu verändern als
andere
das verbot der werksverträge war damals
in der politik nicht durchsetzt war
nicht nur heute ist das nicht wollte
sondern weil die union und die spd an
dieses scharfe schwert nicht rein
wollten noch mal zurück zu dem brief den
gibt es ja was sagen sie dann zu dem
vorwurf denen dieser neffe da erhebt
dass ein engagement eben als
nachträgliche belohnung wahrgenommen
werden könnte und wenn ja wofür was was
könnte er damit gemeint haben dass sich
müssen dienstwagens ist quatsch also
würden sie sagen an diesen vorwürfen ist
nichts dran auch an der
millionenschweren kartellstrafe von der
er spricht wo sie möglicherweise zur
seite gestanden haben um diese eben zu
verhindern ist auch einfach nur im
nachschlagen in ihrer eigenen zeitung
oder ein anderer wenn sie feststellen
dass ich mit dem thema gar nichts zu tun
ich glaube ich war noch nicht mal mehr
im amt als das entschieden wurde und
warum soll ich mich zu solchen vorwürfen
äußern an den haaren herbeigezogen sind
es unsinn was er da schreibt also
absolut nichts dran so ist es